Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we are still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
I taught myself how to do
Facebook advertising.
Narrator:
...by working smart...
I went to Harvard.
I graduated top of my class.
Narrator:
...by thinking big...
We're the third company
in the world
to ever pass
this crash test.
...and chasing their dreams.
All of the stores we sold to
sold out.
‐Oh, wow.
‐I just worked my butt off.
We have raised $2.8 million.
‐Wow.
So, are you a snobby person
yourself?
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank is a safety
device for your loved ones.
♪♪
Aww.
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Juls Bindi
from Austin, Texas.
‐What?
‐All right.
And I'm Carolyn Shewfelt
from Coeur d'Alene, Idaho,
and these are
our spokespooches,
Bentley and ZuGo.
We are looking for $100,000
for 10% of ZuGoPets.
We are revolutionizing
the way pets travel.
As dog owners, we love to take
our dogs everywhere with us.
But having your dog
sit in your lap,
loose in the back seat, or in
an unsecure carrier or crate
can be dangerous
in an accident.
In this crash test,
these are products
that have failed
on the market
in the crash‐test
simulation.
Thank goodness
those are fake dogs.
♪♪
We are passionate
about pet safety.
That's why we have created
the safest way
for you to confidently travel
with your small pet.
We are pleased to introduce...
The Rocketeer Pack.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God.
I know. I know.
‐It may look silly, guys...
‐Oh, my God.
It may look silly, but ‐‐
but, trust us,
The Rocketeer Pack
is the only way to go.
‐Oh.
‐Wait. Wait, wait.
We can't hear you.
Hyenas are laughing.
There is no way.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Oh, come on.
‐Oh, my God. Oh.
‐You've got to be kidding.
I know it looks silly, guys,
but, trust us,
The Rocketeer Pack
is the only way to go.
We're gonna let Bentley
demonstrate how it works.
‐Yes. I want to know.
‐Look at Bentley.
So, the back
of the harness attaches
to The Rocketeer Pack
like so.
Isn't Bentley looking
so stylish in his harness?
You're Velcro'ing
the dog to the seat.
Bindi: There's Velcro
in the back of the harness,
which helps hold
the dog in place
while he does
the tummy strap.
You free the tail. You pull up
on the center buckle.
[ Laughter ]
You secure the shoulders.
And drugs were not involved?
‐No.
‐He's fine. Look at him.
O'Leary: How can he possibly
be happy like that?
Well, it beats
the alternative.
What are you talking about?
Dogs like to stick their
head out the window.
You adjust the straps,
and he's in.
So, you guys
are probably thinking,
"Why is he suspended a couple
inches above the seat?"
which is ideal positioning
to protect the spine.
Bentley is comfortable, but,
most importantly, he's safe.
‐Is he scared in there?
‐He's just really nervous.
Herjavec: You know
what it's like pitching.
[ Chuckles ]
This is the exact same test
that you just saw those other
products fail miserably in.
This is our product,
The Rocketeer Pack,
passing with perfect scores.
But that's not all.
The Rocketeer Pack
comes with front
and backpack attachments,
so when you reach your
destination, you and your pooch
can navigate
those busy streets together.
Ah. Now, I like that, too.
I like the other application.
‐It's like a baby carrier.
That's a great idea.
There must be other products
that do this, right?
No. This is one of a kind.
We have a patent.
You mean nobody else
has a ‐‐ has ‐‐
Greiner: For a seatbelt
for a dog?
I've seen people strapping
on dogs on ‐‐ on bikes.
Shewfelt: Oh, yeah, they do,
but they're not crash‐tested,
and they're
not safety‐approved.
How much does it cost?
It costs $160.
‐Ohh!
‐Oh.
‐What?
‐That's expensive.
‐Hmm.
‐And what's it cost you to make?
Greiner: Is that because
you're making it here?
It costs us $36 to make.
Oh!
That's a huge margin.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐So, what are your sales?
Right now,
our sales is $180,000,
and we just launched it
in November.
Where are you selling them,
then?
We're selling only
on our website.
So, how are
you driving traffic, then?
It's all organic
and word‐of‐mouth.
Wow.
How did you come up
with this?
I actually developed this and
hold the utility patent on it.
The reason
why I started this
is because I have a dog
who has hip and knee injuries,
so I wanted to be able to
travel with them safely.
Wow.
And I couldn't find
anything on the market.
I actually licensed
The Rocketeer Pack off of her.
I really believe
in her project.
So, how much money did you put
into Carolyn's business?
‐How much money?
‐Well, all together,
I put in $200,000.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow.
‐Yeah.
What did you
put the money into?
We went into crash tests
and production.
So far, we have
$200,000 worth of inventory.
Who does the day‐in, day‐out
running of the business?
I do.
What does Carolyn do?
She does all the fulfillment
in her garage.
‐Really?
‐Carolyn, do you know
what the data is
in terms of number of dogs
killed per year
in car accidents?
I don't know that number.
I do know that,
in the United Kingdom,
if you are in an accident
and your dog is unsecured,
it voids your ‐‐
your auto insurance.
Really?
So they are actually putting
those laws into place.
So then ‐‐
then the question is...
Wow.
...do you sell these
in the U. K.?
Yes, we do.
We sell
in 40 different countries.
You must sell one
in each country.
[ Chuckles ]
That's cute.
Like, you haven't sold
that much.
‐But you know what?
‐I like it ‐‐ "Cute."
‐I love that you go, "Cute."
‐I'm just saying.
Cuban: She's used to
dealing with you.
We're the third company
in the world
to ever pass
this crash test.
No other company.
‐Hmm.
This is an $80 billion
industry, guys.
I have twins at home,
and my life right now
is about simplifying.
Like, anything that takes
time to put in, click in,
I don't want anything
to do with it.
There is no way ‐‐
But you do that
for your children.
I do.
But here's my point.
And so what ‐‐
what makes a difference
from your children
from your dog?
But here's my point.
There's no way in the world
I would do this.
It just takes too long.
I‐I think that I do have ‐‐
I'm all about saving time.
Yeah, so, I do have ‐‐
And I'm gonna save you time.
I'm out.
I think
it's too early for me.
To me,
it's not investable yet.
It certainly isn't worth
a million bucks.
No. I'm out.
I love products
that make our loved ones safer.
The problem for me is, I think
that this looks complicated.
I think that you need to
go back to the drawing board
and make it simpler to use,
because it's just not ready yet.
Right now, I'm out.
Okay.
Carolyn and Juls,
I love fighting for animals
and protecting them,
and I didn't even think
about the danger
that I put my pets in
when they're in the car.
So that's what I love
about 10 years of this show.
I learn the most
from people like you
who are educating myself
and the public
about what's going on.
But, right now,
it doesn't seem like you have
everything figured out
for this product just yet.
I think you are
gonna figure it out,
but I think it's just
a little too early, so I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay, guys,
I'm gonna tell you
where your challenge
is gonna be.
Your marketing
isn't good,
because you're not really even
addressing what the problem is.
That's why I asked
the question
of how many dogs
die in car accidents,
because you haven't done
anything that makes it real.
There isn't any statistics
on that.
We have searched everywhere
for those statistics.
Then invent some.
Right? The point is, you ‐‐
You're selling cute...
Mm‐hmm.
...when you should be
selling against fear.
Mm‐hmm.
And I think you really
have to take your marketing
to the next level before
I could even consider.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you all so much
for your time.
Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐All right, thanks, Juls.
‐Congrats on your success.
‐Thank you.
I am really disappointed that
we didn't get a deal today,
but the Sharks gave us some
really good advice in there.
They encouraged us
to just work harder
and to get our stuff in order,
and we're gonna do it.
And we're gonna kill it.
Yep.
♪♪
Hey, guys.
Sand Cloud here from Season 8.
Since airing on "Shark Tank,"
we've done over $15 million
in sales,
and we've launched a whole line
of eco‐friendly products.
We now have the biggest
ambassador program in the world.
And we've been able to
donate over $100,000
to various nonprofits
who specialize
in marine conservation.
So, thank you, "Shark Tank."
Whoo!
♪♪
Narrator: Next in the Tank
is an accessible version
of an often‐intimidating
product.
♪♪
[ French accent ]
Bonjour, le Sharks.
My name is Brice Baillie,
and I'm the founder
of Obvious Wines.
I'm asking for $150,000
in exchange
of 5% of my company.
Yes, you noticed an accent.
I'm originally from
the Champagne region in France,
and I've been living
in Los Angeles
for about
three years and a half.
And I'm here
to talk about wine.
Now, you might be thinking,
"Oh, no, another wine snob
who's only here
to seduce Mr. Wonderful
and will use fancy words
to talk about wine."
Something like,
"Oh, Château Bling‐Bling, hmm.
[ Laughs ]
I love this wine.
Such amazing
Japanese oak notes
and with some hints
of smoked bacon."
[ Speaking French ]
Well, thank you.
It's ‐‐
It's actually the opposite.
Drinking wine is easy, right?
Casual and fun.
Cheers.
And so should be
the way we talk about it
and how we pick it
in a store or in a restaurant,
which is why
I created Obvious Wines.
Obvious Wine
is a curated collection of wines
sold directly
from eco‐friendly vineyards
from all over the world
and created in partnership
with passionate wine makers.
Our wines are packaged
with simple, straightforward,
and educational labels.
Let me show you.
The front label simply talks
about the taste of the wine.
The back label gives you
additional information
about where it's from,
the food pairing,
and the tasting notes
for more advanced consumers.
Ultimately, you know exactly
what to get from our wines,
and you don't need a PhD
to drink them.
So, who wants to taste
some snob‐free wines?
‐Right here, man.
‐Let's try it.
‐Bring it.
‐Let's try.
‐Yeah.
‐Snob‐free wines.
‐Here we go.
‐Oh, hey.
‐Yeah.
♪♪
Merci, Brice.
Oh, two.
Oh, très bien.
It smells really nice.
‐Really nice.
‐Mm‐hmm.
Merci.
♪♪
Sauvignon Blanc.
Exactly. So, there are ‐‐
‐Very good.
‐That's actually really nice.
I don't like white wine.
‐It is nice.
But that's
actually really nice.
‐Very, very nice.
‐Thank you.
Brice,
what's your history?
So, I didn't study wine at all.
I studied business.
And then I started to work
in finance for L'Oréal,
which is
what brought me to the U. S.
I‐I've quit seven month ago
as soon as I got
the distribution licenses.
A week later, I resigned,
and that's...
How ‐‐ How did
you go from L'Oréal
to starting this business?
I started to be
really an enthusiast
about American wines
and California wines,
but I‐I was lost.
And then I realized
that most people around me,
they were not only lost,
but also very intimidated.
Greiner: Oh.
So, in my head, I was like,
"How can we help people
with straightforward labels,
however, to keep very high
quality, as you tasted?"
Why did you decide to give up
your day job to do this?
So, I did a pilot last year
for a few month,
and all of the stores
we sold to,
they purchased again,
and they sold out.
So I‐I‐I know that it sells.
Cuban: They just saw
the labels, and they thought,
"Okay, this is interesting.
Now I know
what I'm talking about"?
Yeah. Yeah.
And there was, like,
a real, like, appetite,
and, again, the ‐‐
the ‐‐ the label is important,
but what's in the bottle
is also very important.
Herjavec: What does
it cost you to import?
What does this cost
landed?
So, retail is $16.
Okay.
But we sell to retailer
for about $11.
Where are you selling them?
And how much
have you sold?
Right now, we sell them
only in Southern California.
I started in February,
so seven month ago.
So, are you going
through a distributor
or selling direct to retail?
We also distribute it.
So I have the importation
and distribution licenses.
We are sold about ‐‐
in more than 100 locations.
We just passed the bar
of $100,000 wholesale.
In ‐‐ In wholesale?
In wholesale,
which is, like, 9,000 bottles.
So, Brice, you're simplifying
the process of buying wine.
Correct.
You're making it less snobby.
Why don't you have
a label like this?
Because I don't
need to do that.
My name, Kevin O'Leary,
is a brand.
People trust me
in the wine business,
and I sell a lot of wine.
So, Brice,
he's not your customer.
But ‐‐
And because ‐‐
And because he thought of it.
No, no, no, but ‐‐
but the market, it's a ‐‐
No, he's ‐‐
he's the anti‐customer.
‐Right.
‐He's the wine snob.
‐He ‐‐ He is the wine snob.
‐Yeah.
Right? He's the whole reason
you created this brand.
Baillie: So...
But I ‐‐ No, I'm not against
what you're doing.
Cuban:
He's trying to take all ‐‐
Kevin, what's the fancy word
you used from previous?
‐The Chevrolet Tastevin.
‐No, no, no, no.
‐Chevaliers du Tastevin.
‐The Chevaliers du Tastevin.
‐Yay!
‐Wow, you said it properly.
Brice,
is that a real thing?
‐Yay!
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
[ Laughter ]
Well, Kevin,
I brought you a tastevin
so you can taste it with it,
actually.
‐Yes, of course.
‐Oh!
‐So it does exist.
‐The brotherhood.
‐It does. It's a real thing.
‐Wait. Kevin.
‐It's ‐‐ It's from Burgundy.
‐Notice how I hold the tastevin.
You'd want to take some
out of the barrel,
put it into the tastevin...
‐Mm‐hmm.
...let the air hit it,
'cause it has a large surface.
‐Mm.
‐[ Sniffs ]
Smell it thusly.
A small sip,
and discard the rest.
‐Huh. And what are you called?
‐Why?
O'Leary: And then say,
"Chevaliers du Tastevin."
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
Together: Yay!
O'Leary:
That's how it works.
I kind of knew
that would happen, but it's...
‐Okay. Back to your story now.
‐Okay, your turn.
How do you make it bigger?
Like, how do you get it
to larger‐scale retailers?
Is that the plan?
So, the way you do that
is showing a success story,
which is what I'm doing right
now in Southern California.
And the way you're gonna do
that is hire salespeople,
have those relationships,
get them out there.
Yeah.
And then it's going and
just contacting those people,
and I actually want to hire
someone who's done that.
Yeah, but, you know, a lot
of times, we joke with Kevin,
but I've seen him work,
you know,
from the beginning
with this.
One day, he called me.
He said, "Hey, I'm at Costco.
I'm doing a tasting
for my wine."
I go over to Costco.
There's a line snaking outside
of Costco around the block.
They have him
chained to a table.
The Costco people
are beating him.
And he has a cheese tray
in one hand.
He was there
for 17 days.
I have a feeling
you're gonna experience that
before this is over.
Building a brand
is extremely difficult.
I'm out.
Thank you, thank you.
I obviously can't do this deal.
I'm competing with myself
if I do.
This year, I'm gonna break
$10 million in wine sales.
That puts me in the top 5%
of guys that make wine.
Really?
Yep.
That's how tough
a business it is.
‐I believe it.
‐Good luck, my friend.
‐Thank you.
‐Chevaliers du Tastevin.
Together:
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
‐Merci.
‐Hey!
‐But I'm out.
‐Thank you.
Cuban: I have a rule.
I do not invest
in any "Shark Tank" companies
that bring out a mime.
For that reason, I'm out.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You don't like the mimes?
Nobody likes mimes
except the mimes.
Yeah.
The mime scared me.
Greiner:
So, great job.
I like the whole concept of it,
and it tastes great.
I also think women are
the biggest wine drinkers.
And ‐‐ And I think, also,
women don't ‐‐
don't try to be snobby
about wine.
They know what they want.
They know what they like.
They don't ‐‐
‐Lori, is there an offer coming?
They don't care. Women
just want their glass of wine
at the end of the day.
And they want something good,
and...
And they want something good.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna make you
an offer.
♪♪
Narrator: Three Sharks are out,
but Lori is interested
in Brice's no‐nonsense
wine company, Obvious Wines.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
‐Hang on. Hang on, Lori.
‐I'm joining ‐‐
Hang on. Hang on.
Brice,
have a glass of wine.
‐Oh.
‐Thank you.
‐To the...
‐Except that ‐‐
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
You took all my wine!
Together: Yay!
‐Cheers.
‐Yay!
[ Chuckles ]
‐Thank you, Robert.
You're just starting,
right?
So I'm willing to take the
journey with you, hand in hand.
I'm gonna offer you
the $150,000,
but I'm gonna ask for...
♪♪
...12.5%
‐That's a yes.
‐Mm.
It's not bad.
‐No?
He's shaking the wine
in his mouth.
‐Hmm.
‐Ah.
‐I have to ‐‐ Then...
‐He has to have a drink.
Think about it. You know
I have an army of women
that are my customers,
and I can get this...
You're crazy to say no
to that.
I can get this name out.
I can get your brand out.
John: She could have crushed
your grapes...
Yes.
...at 20%, but...
I could have.
The valuation, of course,
knowing that I've raised some
money at a higher valuation,
but, of course,
I understand what you bring
is worth much more
than just the money.
Listen. If Kevin can sell wine
on QVC, so can I.
‐Ooh.
‐And...
‐Maybe.
‐...I ‐‐ Of course I can.
I just believe in you.
I also like your branding.
‐Thank you.
I think, in retail,
people will look at that,
and they will pick up
your bottle.
And I think
the wine is fantastic.
Everybody said here
it's phenomenal.
I mean, in my head,
I was hoping, like, 7.5%.
‐Oh, you're gonna blow it.
‐Oh, God.
From 5%?
But you're just starting.
You need muscle.
So, are you,
at the end of the day,
a snobby person yourself?
You came up 2.5%?
10%.
10%. No.
I am worth 12.5%.
I am worth it.
‐She's worth it.
‐I could have gone higher.
I could have gone a lot higher.
You don't understand.
Okay, I have a counter.
Okay.
12 ‐‐ 12.5% for $170,000.
‐Ooh, la, la! Ooh!
‐That's an extra 20 grand.
So it'll be ‐‐
It's just for the valuation.
It's mostly for the investors.
And I understand that you
want ‐‐ you want more than 10%.
And, actually, I like that,
because I know you're
gonna be really involved...
Exactly.
...and you're gonna wake up
in the mor‐‐ in the morning.
For the valuation, I think,
if you want to put
a little bit of money,
then I think
that would be a great deal.
So you want $170,000
for the 12.5%?
Yes.
‐I like this guy.
‐Let's go $160,000.
♪♪
Come on, Brice.
Okay. Okay.
Done?
Deal. Deal.
‐Cool.
‐Chevrolet Tastevin!
‐Yay!
‐Well done.
‐What a deal.
‐Can't believe it.
[ Laughs ]
Wow. Thank you.
You are welcome.
Thank you. Yeah, thank you.
And Kevin
has a competitor now.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations, Brice.
Congratulations.
And please enjoy the wine.
Thank you.
‐Thank you for the wine.
‐Cheers.
‐Salute.
Okay, one last
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
Yeah.
Together:
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
Yay!
♪♪
Baillie:
Having Lori on board is gonna be
a huge step for Obvious Wines.
I think, through her past
businesses and her contacts,
she can help talk
directly to big buyers
and get the product
in front of them.
Together:
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
‐Yay!
‐10 years of "Shark Tank"!
‐Yeah!
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 9,
Ondrea and Marquez Fernandez
struck a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their protein‐packed
doughnut company, The Dough Bar.
We got a deal.
[ Sharks cheering ]
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Ondrea: Today,
we're at the Olympia Fitness
and Performance Expo
in Las Vegas.
Never had
a protein doughnut.
Really?
When people see our booth
and they learn that
we're selling doughnuts,
protein doughnuts,
they go crazy.
We have three new flavors
that we're getting ready
to launch.
We've used
Barbara's investment
to create our brand‐new
cake gluten‐free doughnut.
‐Super‐good.
‐Real good, yes.
Barbara had the idea
to host a focus group
and help us move forward in
rolling out these new products.
I want to tell you
what your job here is today ‐‐
total truthfulness.
Focus groups are important
because it's the easiest way
to get honest feedback.
You can hear how they think on
taste, on price, on packaging,
and you can go home and make
your product even better.
Loved the doughnut so much,
but it was just a little messy
if I were to take it on the go.
I would have liked the glaze
to be a little softer
so, that way, I could put it
on the doughnut
a little bit easier.
I think you could put more
in a box.
I got a box, and I ate
all four in one sitting.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran:
It's great to find out
that you're doing
almost everything right,
but the real value is in hearing
what the criticisms are
and make sure
you have a hit on your hands.
Mason, look.
Marquez: "Shark Tank"
provided so much
for not only our business,
but for our family.
Now,
just nine months later,
we're nearing
$2 million in sales.
The reason Marquez and Ondrea
have done so well
with The Dough Bar
is because they put
their heart and soul behind it,
and they've built
a multimillion‐dollar business.
They're an inspiration
to every entrepreneur out there.
Together: Dough Bar!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a solution
to a common grooming issue.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Noel Durity.
And I'm here seeking $225,000
for a 15% stake in my company...
Twist It Up Combs.
[ Chuckles ]
Twist It Up Combs allows people
with Afrocentric hair...
[ Greiner chuckles ]
...to wake up and embrace
their natural twists.
Now, if you don't have
Afrocentric hair,
you may not realize that
hundreds of millions of people
struggle with this every day.
But not anymore.
Twist It Up Comb is here
to help you style and profile
with no harmful chemicals,
with no tiresome
maintenance routine.
And most of all,
we can finally say bye‐bye
to the painful struggle
of us picking out our hair.
Aah!
[ Thud ]
Wow.
Here's a Twist It Up Comb, man.
Try that out instead.
Sharks, I don't think
you really understand...
[ Laughs ]
...just how wonderful
this comb is.
The comb is compact enough that,
when you go to a bar,
just pull the comb
out your pocket,
and you're ready to meet
your future wife or husband.
[ Laughs ]
Now, Sharks,
without further ado...
Hm.
Deejay, do me a favor.
Drop that beat.
♪ Ever since I got
a Twist It Up Comb ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ My life's been wonderful ♪
♪ Ever since I got
a Twist It Up Comb ♪
Oh!
♪ My life's been wonderful ♪
♪ Ever since I got
a Twist It Up Comb ♪
♪ My life's been wonderful ♪
Man: Yeah.
♪ Ever since I got
a Twist It Up Comb ♪
♪ My life's been wonderful ♪
[ Music ends ]
[ Laughter ]
‐Oh, my God!
‐Who's willing
to twist things up and invest
in the Twist It Up Comb?
‐Ah.
‐Thank you very much.
We're gonna pass out samples.
You know they ain't
gonna let you back home
after that one, right?
‐Thank you.
‐Mr. Wonderful.
‐Daymond.
Enjoy.
‐All right.
‐Mark. Enjoy, enjoy.
‐Thank you, sir.
Okay, so, I need to
understand this...
Yeah.
...technically.
When you were picking
the hair, right...
Yeah.
...it's smooth, right?
Well, so...
And this, you're getting, like,
texture all the way around.
Correct. So, the thing with ‐‐
The thing with Afrocentric hair,
our hair grows up, right?
It doesn't grow down.
So ever since I was born,
I've never had anything
that allowed me to wake up
and embrace my natural hair
without any chemicals,
without having
some special sleep regimen.
Like, it's a ‐‐ it's a process.
Why is the pick
so popular?
So, a pick is hurtful,
for me, anyways.
Like, I won't pick out my hair
unless I go in the shower first.
'Cause it gets caught.
Correct. 'Cause you got to ‐‐
You got to pull, right?
So...
How does this do anything?
It just goes at the top?
Yeah. So, if you...
No. So,
if you look at my hair ‐‐
And I don't know if it's not ‐‐
if it's super‐twisted or not.
When you pull this in, right...
Oh, you have to actually,
like, throw it in there.
Push. And, no, you just do
a nice little circle.
Just go ahead and do it,
Robert.
‐All right. Let me try.
‐Yeah.
‐Doesn't that hurt?
‐No, it does not.
Because it's woven,
it doesn't pull the hair,
which is very important.
If I grow my hair out,
right,
if I take a pick...
Yeah.
...full‐blown Afro comes,
right?
Correct. Correct.
So what this does
is compresses it
and brings it down and then
gives you whatever natural look.
So this is exactly the opposite
of what a pick does.
Correct.
Okay.
Noel, how much
does it cost?
$29.95, and that includes
shipping and tax.
And what's it cost you
to make one?
Around $3.50.
And do you have sales?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, 100%. Yes.
‐Yeah, baby.
All right. Hit me.
My first year,
we only did $95,000.
And this is
all a learning curve, so...
Hey, that's pretty good.
What happened
is that I did a show
at the International Beauty Show
in January.
We sold 500 in three days.
I did $95,000 in 2017.
From January to April,
I did $101,000.
Is this overseas?
Are you making these in China?
So, the meshes
are made overseas,
which is why I have a
manufacturing problem right now.
There is a pollution
done in China right now,
and it's shut down
manufacturing
for, like,
the last 30 to 45 days.
So, what are your sales
this year gonna be?
What do you mean, "a pollution"?
So, if I can get China
back on with the meshes,
I can easily get to $500,000.
Wow.
Noel, is it all online?
It's 70% online,
30% wholesale.
I did a lot of shows last year.
I did about 20.
20 shows? Wow,
that's a lot of shows, so...
Last year, yeah. And it's all ‐‐
It's mostly East Coast.
Okay. And no one's
knocked you off yet?
No. It's patent‐pending.
‐Would a woman use this?
‐Yes!
When you go to New York,
when you go to D. C.,
there is a lot of girls
that they call "TWAs" ‐‐
Tiny with Afros ‐‐
that rock the natural ‐‐
‐"Tiny with Afros"?
‐Correct. Tiny with Afros.
I got to get back to the hood.
Man, I don't...
Tiny with Afros.
I don't know any of this stuff.
[ Laughs ]
Well, yeah.
When you sell it online,
how are you getting
those consumers
to come to your website?
So, I taught myself
how to do Facebook advertising.
Did you buy any ads?
Yes.
And how much
did you spend?
I spent about $18,000
in advertising.
So, what do you need
the money for?
So, definitely inventory.
So, since Day 1
since I created this,
I've had a hard problem
keeping up with inventory.
I've sold out close
to seven times. It's the demand.
When I started doing
the Facebook advertising,
the sales
are coming in nonstop.
So, what ‐‐ what was
your last month in sales?
$41,000.
Okay, so, how much did
you net on that $41,000?
So, I couldn't
really tell you that,
because the problem
is that I‐I prepay
for all my shows
as the money comes in.
So you do it
on a cash basis.
So, do you have anybody
who does your books for you?
Yes.
Okay, so, they don't give you
an income statement
or anything every month?
So, the person
that does my books
got hired, like,
a month and a half ago.
That's not what I like to hear.
I know.
Well, to organize everything.
Before that,
I was doing it myself.
Right.
But to actually
get it down ‐‐
But you weren't printing out
statements to yourself,
so you don't know.
Correct.
Okay. That's not good.
Listen, you're an
amazing guy, man.
Hey, thank you.
I mean,
what a great story.
I love the hustle.
I love the grind.
Yeah.
I loved the dance moves.
[ Laughs ]
But I know nothing
about the product.
You did a great job
explaining it.
But for me to invest,
I got to at least have
a sense for it.
You know,
I wish you all the best.
I appreciate it.
Not for me. I'm out.
♪♪
Oh, and before anyone else steps
out, just to let you know,
I started negotiations
with CVS and Sally's
to get the comb in there.
But why? Look, if you're
killing it online...
I just started
killing it online.
Okay, and so you're doing it
all yourself online, too.
Correct.
And you're teaching yourself
all the SEO
and all the advertising.
‐Correct, correct.
I don't want to get
caught up in the business
of doing more trade shows
and everything.
I try to make ‐‐
I don't either.
Okay, and I'm trying
to make my imprint smaller
in regards to FUBU.
I don't want ‐‐
You know, I like licensing
everything out.
Okay.
I'll give you the $225,000.
But I‐I want to license it out,
to be very honest.
I don't know if that's what ‐‐
the angle that you want to go,
but I would want
25% of the company,
and our objective
is to license.
And it's contingent on us
going out and getting licenses.
Okay, so, my question is to you
that you said the offer
is contingent
on you getting a licensing deal,
meaning that if you don't get
a licensing deal,
then we don't have
a partnership.
Make a counter.
I ‐‐
Then it ‐‐ Then it doesn't
cost you anything,
'cause you had me go out...
‐Yeah, it does. It's la‐‐
It's the last opportunity
'cause he had another deal.
Correct, correct.
I‐I look at it,
I think, "Great idea."
I like the look.
I like what it does.
But in broad, in mass ‐‐
I mean, you ‐‐
Okay, yeah.
If you studied me.
Correct.
‐But I also sell to men.
‐Okay. All right, Noel.
I mean, I'm ‐‐
I'm equal opportunity.
I got ‐‐ I got ‐‐
I got a solution here.
‐Oh.
‐We're gonna come in together.
All right?
‐You're being rude.
He'll deal
with the licensing.
And if he closes
the license deal, he's in.
If he doesn't get
a license deal, he's not in,
and then I give you $225,000
for the 25%.
I can help you
with the Chinese stuff.
I can help
you with the online stuff.
So, same deal ‐‐
$225,000 for 25%.
♪♪
‐Don't think too long.
‐Noel, this is an amazing deal.
‐Yeah, it's good. It's good.
‐$225,000.
I'm enjoying the moment.
I'm taking it in.
‐Savor the moment.
Don't enjoy it too long.
It could go.
This is a once‐in‐a‐lifetime,
you know? Yeah, yeah.
Um...I‐I like that.
Is that a yes?
It's ‐‐ It's a yes.
It's a 100% yes.
‐All right.
‐Yeah.
Yeah, baby.
You're gonna make me wish
I had hair again, man.
‐Congratulations.
‐Appreciate it, man.
‐You were killing me.
‐Oh, let's do the dance!
You'll do really well.
Yeah.
Hey, man.
Time to dance. Go ahead.
Hey, hit the music!
‐Hey!
‐Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey!
‐Am I doing it right?
[ Laughter ]
Durity: Hey!
♪♪
Yay!
I don't know how many times
you're gonna have
some of the most successful
people in the world
want to do a deal with you.
Like, that's surreal.
Like, it's one
of the happiest moments
of an entrepreneur's life.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a business geared
towards the most important
developmental time
for your child.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Zahra
from Oakland, California.
I'm here seeking $200,000 for
2.5% of my company, Monti Kids.
‐Wow.
‐2.5%?
‐Sharks...
85% of the brain
is formed by age 3.
Research shows these early years
are the most critical
for learning,
yet most children under 3
aren't even in school yet.
They're at home,
leaving parents guessing
how to support
their baby's development.
That's why, when I became a mom,
I created Monti Kids
for my kids.
Monti Kids is
a comprehensive learning program
that's designed to fill the gap
from birth
to the school‐age years.
It's based
on the Montessori Method,
and it's easy
for families to use at home.
Families can subscribe any time
between pregnancy and age 3.
Every three months, they receive
a box of Montessori toys
tailored to their child's
stage of development.
For parents, we send
weekly e‐mails with videos
that show them how to introduce
the toys like an expert.
Of course, results may vary.
Monti Kids
is not a toy subscription.
It's an educational program
that gives children
a strong foundation for learning
right from birth.
So, Sharks, who wants to
help give children
the very best start?
Do you have some examples
of some things?
I ‐‐ Yeah, I have some samples
for you, actually.
Any one?
Any one you like.
Okay.
Whatever calls to you.
Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐You're welcome.
‐Good job, Lori.
Quickly. Good.
‐What did you do?
‐Thank you.
Kassam: Oh, you're welcome.
I think I take it out
and put it back in.
‐[ Laughing ] Yeah.
‐Yeah.
So, how ‐‐
how about this one, Zahra?
What's the deal here?
Kassam: So ‐‐ So, that...
I got a blue ball.
This is for ‐‐
What ‐‐ What am I learning
here ‐‐ ball in hole?
So, this is called
object permanence.
So, little babies,
around 5 months,
if you put the ball in the hole,
they're not gonna look for it.
They don't understand that
that ball is still there.
Around 7, 8 months,
they start learning,
"It's gone, but I can look
for it and find it."
Are you interviewing
2‐month‐olds
and asking what they like?
So, this is based
on the Montessori Method.
The Montessori Method has been
around for over 100 years
in 20,000 schools
around the world.
So, effectively, this is
do‐it‐yourself Montessori.
Exactly. For 0 to 3,
because 0 to 3 Montessori
is not accessible.
Those 20,000 Montessori schools
around the world
mostly start at age 3 and up.
You seem quite an expert,
so tell us about you.
Sure. So, I went to Harvard.
I studied psychology.
I graduated top of my class,
summa cum laude.
I got my master's
from the Harvard
Graduate School of Education,
and then I became
a Montessori‐trained teacher...
‐Wow.
‐...internationally certified
for babies
from birth to age 6.
The real deal.
I was teaching
in Montessori preschool.
I absolutely loved it.
And then my first child
was born.
And the school where I was
working started at age 3,
like most preschools
around the world.
And, given my background,
I know that 0 to 3,
it's the most important time
for their learning
for their foundation.
Zahra, if I was a customer...
Yes.
...and I wanted to sign up,
what would I pay?
How would it work?
So, we have eight levels.
A level lasts two,
three months.
Including all the content
for the parents, it's $297.
‐$297?!
‐For three months?
‐For those two shelves of toys?
‐Three months.
‐Do you send it back after that?
‐You do not,
because your child
is not gonna stop using this
after three months.
They're gonna use it ‐‐
So, Zahra, I get
one, two, three, four,
five, six toys for $300.
Yes.
And the content, which is
actually the most valuable part
for a lot of parents.
What does it cost you to make
all this stuff and send them?
So, $120 is our cost.
Zahra, do you have
tons of sales?
Like, 'cause you're asking
for $200,000 for 2.5%.
So, we have been selling
for 14 months,
and we've done $550,000
in sales.
Well, good for you. That's good.
Thank you.
Oh, hey, that's very good.
We're growing 20% month
over month since we launched.
What did you make
on $550,000? Anything?
No, we're ‐‐ we're making the
decision to ‐‐ to raise money
to invest
to grow exponentially.
Have you raised any money
at any valuations prior?
We have raised ‐‐
Of course she has.
She went to Harvard.
So?
We have raised
$2.8 million to date.
‐Wow!
‐Oh! That's the valuation!
Kassam: There's a huge need
in the market.
Parents are looking for learning
and development resources
for their babies,
and there is a gap.
The re‐‐
You know, the gap I described.
But that all exists.
So, there is
actually a lot of differences,
and they're
nuanced differences.
You won't find toys
that are as simple as ours.
With all due respect,
there are things like this.
There's also ‐‐
It's just really telling us
why is yours better when
you're not apples to apples.
So...
So, the ‐‐ the aspect
of a program.
So, for a parent
to know when ‐‐
what age do you give that
to a child
and how do you present it
to them
and what ‐‐ how do you ‐‐
So it's really
the learning method.
It's not hard to do. It's not
hard to look up on YouTube.
Greiner:
When you first walked in,
I thought,
"Ooh, interesting."
Like, I‐I really get it.
But where I have a problem is,
I do feel that most people,
it would be very difficult
to pay $1,200 a year
to go into toys.
I would love to bring
our price down as we grow.
But, Zahra, most of us grew up
with nothing here on the panel.
I mean, I grew up
with a stick and a rock.
Robert was playing
with a rat on a boat
coming over here from Croatia.
It was a nice rat, though.
Kevin had a wooden nickel
he was playing with.
I mean ‐‐
And we turned out okay.
And you want to give your
children more than what you had.
Well, listen.
I assume.
I mean, I'll ‐‐
I'll be very honest.
With an ‐‐
an $8 million valuation...
This is a ‐‐
a huge global opportunity.
We have customers
buying our ‐‐ our products
from all over the world.
I got it. I got it. But listen.
But listen, Zahra. Zahra.
Sorry.
Just good luck.
I'm out.
Thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it.
I just want to tell you ‐‐
O'Leary: Zahra, how much cash
do you have in the bank
right now?
We have $200,000 in the bank
right now,
and then we have commitments
coming in.
And what's your burn rate
right now?
We are burning
about $95,000 a month.
‐A month?
‐You know how I ‐‐
‐Oh!
‐Yeah. But we have ‐‐
‐A month?
We have a team of six people
right now.
You better ‐‐ You better
cut that down to three.
O'Leary: Zahra, you've got
to get the whacking stick out.
We have $500,000
in commitments...
Like that thing.
Start whacking people.
...from investors coming in,
and I'm here to make a deal,
because...
God, Zahra, as much
as I love you...
‐Yes?
‐Whoa.
...and I love
what it does for kids,
$200,000 for 2.5%?
I'm sorry.
That's just too rich
for my blood.
I'm out.
‐Okay, okay.
‐Staying on the numbers,
you've done $550,000
since inception.
Did you have any net on that,
or what are your losses to date?
So, we're losing about $20,000
a month right now.
Okay, so, how much
have you lost in aggregate?
About $900,000.
[ Inhales sharply ]
We just increased our burn.
We just moved into an office.
We just hired someone
who's doing school partnerships
and mom ambassador marketing.
But how you allocate your
resources is ‐‐ is critical.
Well, so, starting this up,
I talked about the story
of designing, manufacturing...
Right. No, I get it.
But it goes to the heart
of decision‐making, right?
You've gone through
$2.6 million,
and you are so committed
to that what you have
is so much better
than everything else,
your decision‐making
in terms of being a business
i‐is not what I'd want to
see in a business.
But, Mark ‐‐
And for those reasons, I'm out.
Can I ‐‐
Here's where I'm at.
Anybody else besides you
standing up there
with your $2.8 million raised,
$2.6 million gone,
$90,000 burn rate per month
would not be smiling
anymore.
[ Laughs ]
It's a horrible story.
But for some reason,
you have
this incredibly
captivating character
that we're still listening
to you.
So, you have
a great degree.
Harvard sounds really fancy,
but you missed one school.
You didn't go
to the school of hard knocks.
Somebody like you
that burns through
$2.6 million like that
tells me you've missed
a reality in life
of how hard it is to get
that kind of money.
I understand that. We ‐‐
You know
what you're missing?
You're missing discipline.
We started the company ‐‐
You're missing discipline
today. That's what you are.
Thank you for the feedback.
So, because of
your incredible ability
with this crazy story
and I still like you,
I want to be in on it.
I think there's a market,
and I have twins.
Okay.
But...
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Robert is concerned about
the huge amount of money
Zahra has already spent
on her Montessori‐based
toy‐subscription company,
Monti Kids,
but he's still interested.
I want to be in on it.
I think there's a market,
and I have twins.
Okay.
But...
Can I just tell you ‐‐
But no!
Okay, sorry. Go ahead.
See?
No, no, no.
That's what I'm talking about.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Please.
I'm gonna make you an offer,
and you kept talking. Shh.
Okay.
So, here's what I like.
I love the market.
I love where you're going.
I know how hard it is
to raise money,
and I know
how to get revenue.
Okay.
You got to ramp up
the revenue.
Yes.
Here's my offer.
I'll give you the $200,000,
I'll come on the board,
I'll help you
run this thing,
'cause I really believe
in it.
But I want 10%,
'cause that's how much value
I think
I can bring to it.
'Cause if you don't get
somebody like me with reality,
you're gonna go
off a cliff.
He's right.
That's my offer.
Can I just say that ‐‐
Thank you so much.
O'Leary: I'll tell you
what I'm willing to do.
I listened to this story,
and just from the blank piece
of paper, listening to numbers,
they're horrific.
You're ‐‐ You're gonna
burn out in six weeks.
You won't have any cash.
But you really require
some adult supervision.
I'm not kidding. So here's
the only deal I'd consider.
I'll give you the $200,000,
I'm taking the 2.5%,
which is meaningless equity
at this point.
I‐I mean, it ‐‐ I wouldn't
even get out of bed for 10%.
But I'm gonna put
a royalty on it.
I want $10 a unit until
I get back my $200,000,
so you have to sell 20,000
of these things, right?
Then I want to go down
to $2.50 a unit
till I get back
another $600,000,
and then it goes away.
That's venture debt.
‐We ‐‐
‐The huge smile on your face
that has been here the entire
time, I watched it just sink.
No, but you're ‐‐
You got to face reality here.
I mean, you're very,
you know, tenacious.
I love the story.
Kassam: Yes.
You know,
you're very credible.
I had dyslexia
when I was young.
I used all kinds of
wooden blocks and all this.
I still have it.
But I went through
the learning process.
I'm a believer in the ‐‐
in ‐‐
in the whole
Montessori system.
Zahra, you're not growing
quickly enough
to take on venture debt.
So ‐‐ So, can I just say
that we have cash coming in?
Right.
We also have the ability
to get more cash if we need it,
but I'm gonna be disciplined.
You have two offers.
Make a decision.
Robert.
♪♪
Zahra.
Would you consider $200,000
for 5%.
No.
Okay.
And is there any way, Kevin,
you would consider doing
more money for more equity
without a royalty?
No, because the structure
I'm providing you with
forces you to be very focused
on paying me back.
Robert,
would you consider $200,000
for 5% of equity
and 5% advisor's shares?
Just so we can ‐‐
I don't care how you
structure it.
Okay.
You want to give me
5% advisory?
Yes.
I'm okay with that.
$200,000 for 10%.
Would you consider
working together?
Hang on, Zahra.
Cuban: You've just
proven our point.
You realize that.
John: She's talking
her way out of this.
Well, I'm ‐‐
I'm talking about the value
of getting two Sharks.
You are, but you're talking
your way out of this.
I just want to
put it out there.
You ‐‐ You had a deal.
You came to a deal.
You negotiated a deal.
Robert, let's do it.
No. Sorry.
I don't want to do it.
Seriously.
You're treating money
like it's some hypothetical
Harvard project.
I ‐‐
I gave you an offer.
You tried to give me
founder shares.
I said yes. I said yes once.
I said yes twice.
I said yes three times,
and what do you do?
I ‐‐
You say, "Do you want
to work with Kevin"?
I just was trying to get
multiple Sharks in.
Everybody wants to
work with Kevin.
I was trying to get
multiple Sharks in.
Oh, come on.
But I ‐‐ Honestly,
I'm so grateful ‐‐
I work really hard
for my money.
If I was you, after
I've lost all that money,
I wouldn't play around.
When it's real money,
it's really important to me.
I'm sorry, but
I‐I‐I don't want to do it.
You want to do a deal with
Kevin? Do a deal with Kevin.
I'm out.
Well, then. All roads
lead back to Mr. Wonderful.
♪♪
I ‐‐ You know what?
I recognize
the value you bring,
and I would love to do
a deal, Kevin.
♪♪
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
♪♪
Kevin, he gave us our ask,
and he added a royalty to it.
And, you know,
a royalty works well
when a company
is really successful,
and I think we're gonna be
really successful
because of this.
So I think it was a great deal.
Herjavec: It's ridiculous.
I have to tell you...
Oh, my God.
...I am really tired
of people
with fancy degrees
and theoretic principles.
Robert, what does that
have to do with anything?
A bird in the hand...
Cuban: Here she comes.
She doesn't know.
Listen, Robert.
Learn from me, grasshopper.
She has no discipline.
Now she has you.
♪♪